ja ich habe mir schon gedacht dass hier
in der runde bestimmt viel von den
nachwehen der wahl die rede sein würde
das hat sich jetzt mal ganz bewusst ein
thema mitgebracht das in den letzten
anderthalb tagen und leider auch in den
letzten anderthalb jahren wirklich nicht
die aufmerksamkeit bekommen hat die ist
eigentlich bedienen würde nämlich die
versorgungslage von psychisch kranken
menschen ja also ich glaube in der grund
ab animiert ist jeder miterleben können
vielleicht am eigenen leib oder
zumindest im eigenen freundes und
bekanntenkreis ist schlug den leuten
aufs gemüt es ist ja auch überhaupt
nicht überraschend auf der einen seite
die ständige angst vor ansteckung vor
krankheit im schlimmsten fall ford roth
auf der anderen seite aber natürlich
auch die ärzte monatelange soziale
isolation teilweise zeit aber welt
teilweise arbeitslosigkeit teilweise
vereinsamen und im home office bei
schwierigen betreuungsverhältnissen von
den kindern will ich erst gar nicht
anfangen also das sind alles enorme
belastungsfaktoren und man kann das auch
in zahlen ausdrücken indem man nämlich
darauf hinweist dass seit beginn der
pandemie die anfragen neuer patienten in
therapiepraxen und 40 prozent gestiegen
sind und dieser anstieg trifft leider
auf eine situation auch das kann man in
zahlen fassen die schon vorher desolat
war also schon vorher hat man als neuer
patient auf den therapieplatz vier bis
fünf monate gewartet dass wir bei jeder
anderen vergleichbar schweren
krankheiten gibt unvorstellbar bei
psychischen erkrankungen ist es leider
denn normalfall und ich muss sagen ich
finde es zum einen extrem scheinheilig
bin der als gesellschaft auf der einen
seite sagen ja es gibt krankheiten das
ist ganz normal das kann jedem mal
passieren da muss man sich nicht
beschweren wenn man sich hilfe suchen
dann aber den die sich hilfe suchen
wollen sagen ja tut uns furchtbar leid
und müsstest du jetzt erst mal zwanzig
bis dreißig praxen abtelefonieren wozu
die schon kaum noch in der lage bist und
dann klappt es vielleicht in einem
halben jahr glück hast punkt eins und
dann punkt 2 und damit komme ich auch
zum ende ist ist nicht nur scheinheilig
sondern es ist auch einfach eine
wahnsinnige fehlallokation von
aufmerksamkeit von problembewusstsein
und von finanzieller opferbereitschaft
wenn man sich mal anschaut auf der einen
seite welche summen ziemlich
schulterzuckend ausgegeben worden sind
sowie kämpfen wer einen krankheit des
corona virus will gar nicht sagen das
ist falsch war aber welche im vergleich
wirklich lächerlich geringen summen
leider offensichtlich nicht zur
verfügung stehen dieses problem das
gerade auch sehr viele junge und
mittelalte menschen betrifft und
teilweise sie das leben kostet halbwegs
wirksam in den griff zu kriegen das
finde ich hat die letzte bundesregierung
wirklich versorgt und ist eine dringende
aufgabe für die nächste wie auch immer
sie aussehen achtung der constantin am
anfang der sendung waren wir uns ja
nicht grün ist unsere aussagen jetzt
muss ich sagen kann ich dir nun zu
applaudieren ich sehe das 121 ganz
genauso was aber für mich noch viel mehr
das versagen des staates ist was man
leicht ändern könnte psychologie ist ja
ein totaler eliten studiengang also wenn
man als kind irgendwie nicht zwei
akademiker eltern hat oder auch
handwerker denn die gut verdienen kann
man sich das ja gar nicht leisten die
psychotherapeutin ausbildung nicht dass
ich von einem thema weg finden will aber
die kostet danach ja auch noch mal über
20.000 euro das heißt immer weniger
menschen wir hatten psychologen also der
staat dem sind auch jetzt ist es auch
egal wie viele jetzt depression haben
aber auch in den letzten jahren ist
wurde gar nichts dafür getan dass wir
mehr plätze haben und dass wir nicht so
viel dass das führt überhaupt nicht
davon weg sondern greift eigentlich
nahtlos hinein denn es sind nicht nur
wie du schon gesagt dass in der tat erst
mal vier bis fünf jahre studium dann
noch einmal drei bis fünf jahre
ausgehalten dann kommt ja der
eigentliche spaß wenn du nämlich als
psychotherapeut ist dann niederlassen
willst und zumindest mal die 90 prozent
der bevölkerung die gesetzlich
krankenversichert sind auch irgendwie
als deine kunden haben möchtest dann
brauchst du was einen kasten sitzt und
das ist ja das problem des übels den
kaufst du dann nämlich erst mal und zwar
im beliebten gegenden gerne mal für
200.000 euro das heißt du startest
extrem verschuldet ins berufsleben was
dann auch wieder um fehlanreize
wahrscheinlich setzt für die
berufsausübung die anschließende und
warum naja weil die kostensätze
künstlich knapp gehalten werden es gäbe
zumindest momentan durchaus genug
psychotherapeuten es gibt um die 55.000
aber nur 25.000 kassen ist sehen würde
ich mich am ende der bin ich ruhig zu
einer these hinreißen lassen es werden
nicht die begabtesten unserem land
psychologen sollen es werden die
reichsten unserem land psychologen das
ist wirklich ein thesis welchen
hinreißen also ich habe auch ein paar
fälle im freundeskreis wir die wirklich
jetzt überlegen ob sie
die sind ja super gau
sich jetzt überlegen ob sie das geld
nehmen nach dem studium nach den ganzen
jahren dann noch mal mit 29 jahren waren
und jetzt 5000 euro aufnehmen ich finde
wirklich ein unding deswegen ich finde
es ganz toll dass das thema aufgebracht
dass im privaten beschäftige mich dieses
thema sehr und ich finde es ein unding
dass menschen eigentlich kaum
psychologen werden können außerdem
finanzielles polster also ich habe immer
diese frage noch nie so intensiv
nachgedacht und mir waren noch die
zahlen nicht so bewusst und ich denke
darüber nach woran messen wir eigentlich
wie es unserem land geht wir messen es
am bruttosozialprodukt wir müssen es an
der arbeitslosenzahl also wir haben so
einige indikatoren
und bei diesen zahlen kommt man ja
schnell auf die idee dass man eigentlich
einen hinzufügen müsste ein indikator
nämlich die zahl der psychisch kranken
das ist nämlich ein ergebnis eines
gesellschaftlichen zusammenlebens und
auch ein ergebnis von politik und die
stelle jetzt gehört mir vor dieser wert
würde neben den anderen werten zur
erfolgsbilanz einer gesellschaft zählen
dann wäre es vermutlich auch einfacher
die mittel zu lukrieren und zu sammeln
um etwas zu tun und und sensibilität zu
schaffen wird das wirst du zum beispiel
oder was ihr gemeinsam gesagt habt auf
der seite derjenigen die sich um solche
patienten kümmern wollen solange das in
so einer merkwürdigen nische zwischen
nah er ist halt ein bisschen traurig und
der da ist noch so sind auch noch die
absage und dann sind ein paar vielleicht
wirklich krank ich komme jetzt fällt mir
gerade einen immer wenn über
depressionen geredet wird dann wird es
ja tendenziell auch verniedlicht zum
glück in letzter zeit nicht mehr so
wahrscheinlich braucht man eine einen
indikator den man in der öffentlichkeit
diskutiert und mit dem man politik
verpflichtet mindestens so viel zu tun
wie für die arbeitslosen damit die
wieder arbeit gegen für psychisch kranke
damit sie wieder gesund werden können
das wäre mal ein gedankengang der sich
lohnte ja also untersuchung zur
häufigkeit von psychischen erkrankungen
gibt es liefen allerdings wirklich
erschreckende zahlen ja also da kommt
man ungefähr auf 25 bis 30 prozent der
bevölkerung die pro jahr zumindest eine
klinisch relevante diagnose an das sind
jetzt natürlich nicht alles leute die
durch die straße laufen und glauben sie
wären irgendwie john f kennedy oder soja
das ist schon klar dass ich das nicht in
dem bereich abspielt das heißt aber
deshalb noch lange nicht dass es nicht
trotzdem der relevant sein kann sie sind
einfach im alltag meistens erstaunlich
gut darin ihre probleme zu verstecken
und die wartezeiten die ich eben genannt
habe die ja schon eigentlich
erschütternd lang sind kommen natürlich
trotzdem nur dadurch zustande und so
andernfalls wären sie eben noch viel
länger dass sehr viele leute einfach
überhaupt keine hilfe sich suchen oder
ist zwar versuchen aber keine bekommen
aber es passieren gleich gesagt das ist
das problem ja ich glaube dass man ihn
nicht in der öffentlichkeit so
wirkungsmächtig ist ich kann mich noch
gut erinnern beim suizid von robert enke
während lockte dieses thema auf einmal
auf wochenlang wurde dieses thema in den
medien behandelt auch als unerkannte
erkrankung und die ernsthaftigkeit
dieser erkannte stroms hat gesagt man
sieht jemand aber der ist aber traurig
aber wird auch schon wieder werden dann
kam auch der freitod des hessischen
finanzminister schäfer dann kommt dieses
thema wieder hoch aber ich kann nicht
feststellen dass die betroffenen auch
die angehörigen kann ja für sie auch
eine tragödie sein so organisiert sind
und sie so in der öffentlichkeit gehör
verschaffen können wie andere gruppen
die ja jetzt gerade in der pandemie
große rolle gespielt am krankenschwester
pflegerin altenpflegerin altenpfleger
die doch sehr stark auch im fokus des
öffentlichen interesses stand und die
risiken und nebenwirkungen der korona
politik die haben wir auch noch nicht
endgültig ausgelöscht ausgelöst ist
glaube ich ein wichtiger punkt und den
vorschlag die du gemacht hast klaus der
ist glaube ich sehr sehr überlegenswert
und wenn man das zusammenbindet das was
du gesagt hast du was herr bosbach
gesagt hat dann fällt das doch auf und
das glaube ich beherrscht politik nicht
oder beherrschen regierung nicht in so
genannten ökonomen sagen
opportunitätskosten sehr komplizierter
begriff zu denken was heißt das in
verzichts kosten zu denken wenn ich
mache was kostet mich das an anderer
stelle also bedeutet wenn ich ein
lockdown verhänge dann so war die leser
der regierung dann verhindern dass
menschen an kroner sterben aber was
kostet es mich eigentlich auf der
anderen seite im sinne von welche
zusätzlichen kranken produziere ich ein
und damit meine ich nicht nur dass krebs
operationen verschoben werden sondern
welche zusätzlichen kranken kostet mich
handeln handeln lockdown möglicherweise
weniger monate kostet aber b mehr
menschen mit krankheiten wie
depressionen angstzuständen und so
weiter und so fort und ich glaube in
diesen kategorien zu denken das heißt
nämlich dann doch nicht alternativlos
sondern es gibt viele alternativen
das müssen regierungen wirklich
beherzigen das tun sie viel zu selbst
sagt immer dass der weg den gibt es die
kosten die sonst anfallen oder andere
effekte die interessieren mich gerne
aber diese entscheidend ich habe kurz
zwischenrufen auch diese
opportunitätskosten die sie richtig
beschrieben haben müssen dann allerdings
auch für andere ausgabepositionen geld
kann ich auch nicht sagen ihrem sohn so
für kurzarbeiter geld ausgegeben das
hätten wir uns sparen können was hätte
uns das gekostet wenn wir das nicht
getan hätten oder die kolosse
überraschend euro gehen absolut richtig
aber ein anderer schüler auf je nach
kurzarbeit bedeutet jetzt dass das geld
ist ja für die kurzarbeit audi vom
himmel gefallen das zahle die künftigen
generationen einmal über die nächsten
jahre mit einem höheren
arbeitslosenbeitrag muss man immer sagen
ist nicht vom oder wir haben es aus dem
bundeshaushalt gezahlt da müssen die
steuerzahler bezahlt also da hat der
steuerzahler die jobs subventioniert
muss man einfach da man das geld hätten
wir uns sparen doch irgendwann wäre
billiger wir hätten zwar anders
reinstecken das ist eine andere frage
schulen also es gibt den euro kann man
nur einmal ausgeben und die frage ist
immer wo ist er besser ausgegeben und
das muss man glaube ich viel stärker in
den fokus nun ganz kurz denen wir unsere
zeit neigt sich langsam dem ende zu es
immer wie bei der sammlung man kann
schon sehr gucken was würdest du dir den
wünschen von der region sind blick auf
die aktuellen zahlen kurzes statement
was sollen sie machen einfach einen
klaren auftrag an den gemeinsamen
bundesausschuss der diese dinge dann ja
letzten endes verwaltet und beschließt
zu formulieren in dem bereich deutlich
nach zu helfen und dann erst ist nämlich
alles so zu sagen dass das große wort in
der gesundheitspolitik die
bedarfsplanung mal verrückte idee
tatsächlich an bedarf auszurichten und
nicht wie es nämlich leider bisher der
fall ist absurder weise an der
versorgungslage im jahr 1999 kein scherz
die bilder tatsächlich den maßstab für
die zahl von psychotherapeuten im land
das kann es nun wirklich nicht sein
[Musik]